chaque matin c'est le même rituel à les
actes de pontarlier la prise de
température est obligatoire c'est des
mesures qui nous servent parce que ses
personnages sur le handicap et que pas
forcément tout cela la capacité de
verbaliser le fait qu'ils ont acquises
ont des symptômes
près de 150 personnes en situation de
handicap travail ici quotidiennement le
confinement est loin d'avoir réduit
l'activité de la blanchisserie
car avec la crise sanitaire les besoins
hospitaliers ont explosé moi je me sens
acteurs deux acteurs de tout ça quoi de
ce2 ce2 virus de fin de cette lutte
contre le virus ont à dire à un peu quoi
d un peu participants la pourrait dire
ispagnacois faut bien trouver un deal à
givat produits linge quoi voilà
contrairement au printemps dernier le
personnel peut donc cette fois ci se
rendre sur site
un soulagement pour bon nombre d'entre
eux j'ai fait mal supporté le premier
confinement sans pouvoir venir bosser
donc ça me fait du bien et je me sens
utile mal que
mokobé de malgré des situations
identiques à les adh de morteau bien que
la cafétaria soient fermées au public
l'activité de production culinaire est
elle maintenue ici près de 2000 repas
sont préparés tous les jours enfin
manger principalement pour des écoles
primaires maternelles crèches
voilà principalement et pour des foyers
de personnes handicapées et personnes
âgées pour ça qu on continue notre
activité parce que il faut bien fournir
à manger à personne en franche comté une
vingtaine d'établissements et services
d'aidé par le travail tourne en ce
moment à plein régime